hey everyone welcome to another video by
simply learn
in this video called keras tutorial we
will teach you everything that you need
to know about keras in machine learning
and data analysis to begin we will
explain the concept of keras to you
we will answer the question what is
keras and how it is used in deep
learning then
we will list out some common differences
between keras tensorflow and pi torch so
that you can understand why keras is the
superior framework after this we will
dive deep into keras and see how you can
use keras to implement deep learning
models with hands-on tutorials and
finally we will take a look at keras
sequential models a type of model and
keras which makes implementing neural
networks extremely easy
so
let's get started the first question
that arises in our mind is what is deep
learning deep learning is generally
considered to be a subset of machine
learning which is nothing but a subset
of artificial intelligence what is
artificial intelligence artificial
intelligence is the intelligence which
is demonstrated by machines unlike the
natural intelligence which is displayed
by humans and animals which also
involves consciousness and emotionality
meanwhile machine learning is an
application of artificial intelligence
that provides systems the ability to
automatically learn and improve from
experience without being programmed to
specifically now deep learning as i said
is a class of machine learning
algorithms that uses multiple layers to
progressively extract higher level
features from raw input for example if
we have a system which we are using for
image processing lower layers in the
system may be used to detect the
outlines of images while higher layers
may identify the concepts which are
relevant to the image in case of the
picture of a human it might recognize
features such as digits or letters or
face now in deep learning we use neural
networks to use multiple mathematical
operations to break down a complex
problem into smaller parts which are
solved individually each mathematical
expression is called a neuron
deep learning models are trained using
large sets of labeled data and neural
network architectures that learn
features directly from the data without
the need for manual feature extraction
one of the most popular types of deep
neural networks is known as a
convolution neural network a convolution
neural network convolves learned
features with input data and uses 2d
convolutional layers making this
architecture well suited processing 2d
data such as images
now in deep learning neural networks
will play a very important part what
exactly are neural networks
neural networks are modeled from the way
the human brain works
in our brain we have neurons which carry
electrical impulses from our brain to
different parts of our body and help in
transmitting instructions from the brain
all over our body in neural networks a
neuron acts as nothing more but a
mathematical operation
multiple neurons are required to break
down a complex problem into various
paths to make it easier to solve
now a neural network contains layers of
interconnected nodes each node in a
neural network is a perceptron and is
similar to a multiple linear regression
the perceptron feeds the signals which
are produced by multiple linear
regressions into an activation function
that may be non-linear hidden layers
will fine-tune the input weightings
until neural network's margin of error
is minimal and we get the optimal output
now what is keras
before we move on to keras let's take a
look at tensorflow tensorflow is a
software library which was created by
google to implement large-scale machine
learning models and to help solve
complex numerical problems tensorflow is
an end-to-end open source machine
learning platform which you can think of
as an infrastructure layer for
differentiable programming it combines
four key abilities
first efficiently executing lower level
tensor operations on cpu and gpu or tpu
computing gradient of arbitrary
differential expressions scaling
computation to many devices and
exporting programs to external runtimes
such as servers browsers or mobiles
but what does keras have to do with all
of this keras is nothing more than a
high level deep learning api which is
written in python for neural networks it
has multiple backend neural network
computations and it makes implementing
neural networks easy
as we know keras is a powerful and easy
to use free open source python library
for developing and evaluating deep
learning models
keras is a high level api of tensorflow
2
an approachable highly productive
interface for solving machine learning
problems with a focus on modern deep
learning it provides essential
abstractions and building blocks for
developing and shipping machine learning
solutions with high iteration velocity
keras empowers engineers and researchers
to take full advantage of the
scalability and cross-platform
capabilities of tensorflow 2. you can
run keras on tpu or on large classes of
gpu and you can export your keras model
to run in the browser or on a mobile
device keras provides a python interface
for artificial neural networks keras
acts as an interface for tensorflow
library and it helps in implementation
of commonly used neural network building
block layers such as objectives
activation functions and optimizers and
a host of tools to make working with
images and text data easier to simplify
the coding necessary for writing deep
neural network code
basically it wraps efficient numerical
computation libraries such as theano and
tensorflow and allows you to define and
change neural network models in just a
few lines of code in fact tensorflow and
keras are so tight together that even in
tensorflow the official get started with
tensorflow tutorial views high-level
keras apis embedded in tensorflow
instead of just using tensorflow by
itself
some of the important features of keras
include keras being a high level
interface which uses theano or
tensorflow for its backend
keras can run smoothly on both cpu and
gpu
it supports almost all the models
required for you to create a complete
neural network
and it is extremely modular in nature
which means it is incredibly expressive
flexible and apt for innovative research
so why do we need keras
first of all keras is an api which is
designed for human beings not for
machines which means that it follows
best practices for reducing cognitive
load it offers consistent and simple
apis it minimizes the number of users
action required for common use cases and
it provides clear and actionable
feedback upon
user error
it is extremely powerful and easy to use
and it also wraps numerical computation
libraries such as theano and tensorflow
and allows you to train and define
neural networks in a few lines of code
this makes keras easy to learn and use
as a keras user you can be more
productive allowing you to try more
ideas than your competition faster which
in turn will help you win machine
learning competition this ease of use
does not come at the cost of reduced
flexibility because keras integrates
deeply with low level tensorflow
functionality it enables you to develop
highly hackable workflows where any
piece of functionality can be customized
or reused easily
building a model in keras let's take a
look at the basic pipeline which you
will have to follow when you are using
keras to define a neural network first
of all you will have to define a neural
network you will have to select the
activation functions and the various
mathematical operations that are gonna
be taking place in your neural network
along with the different weightages
next you will use keras to compile your
network which is basically you will use
keras to build it
after this you will fit to your network
you will fit all the training data that
you have to your network
and use your testing data to evaluate
how the network works
finally you will use this network to
make predictions
this entire five-step pipeline can be
executed in keras within two to three
lines of code neural networks which
would have taken people days or even
weeks to make can be executed in keras
in a couple of hours
now users of keras
the first use of keras is to productize
deep models on smartphones deep models
require a lot of computation power to
run but with the help of keras we can
literally make deep models a product
which can be sold and executed on
smartphones
the next use of keras is in distributed
training of deep learning models
distributed training means that we can
split our deep learning model into
different paths and train it on systems
all across the globe this makes training
of our deep learning model extremely
fast along with saving time we are also
saving on the computational power of our
system as it is not only our system
which has to run such a heavy program by
distributing it across various systems
all the resources required to train a
deep learning model go down
significantly before we can see the
differences between these platforms we
first need to know what exactly each of
these platforms are let's start with
tensorflow what is tensorflow tensorflow
is a low level software library which is
created by google to help implement
machine learning models and to solve
complex numerical problems
tensorflow is nothing but a free and
open source software library for machine
learning
it can be used across a range of tasks
but has a particular focus on training
and inference of deep neural networks
tensorflow is a symbolic math library
based on data flow and differential
programming it is used for both research
and production at google
what do you mean by data flow it
basically means that we perform
calculations by converting every element
into graphical form
the variables of the graph are called
tensors and mathematical operations are
called operators
here in the computational graph shown
you can see that x y and 2 are the
variables they will also be called
tensors and division multiplication and
addition are the operators
this graph basically shows us the
calculation that is going to occur in a
machine learning model
where x and y are going to be divided
and y and 2 are going to be multiplied
the results of these two calculations
are then going to be added to give us
the final output i told you that x y and
2 are also called tensors
what exactly are tensors
tensors are multi-dimensional arrays
with a uniform type all tensors are
immutable like python numbers and
strings which means that you cannot
update the contents of a tensor you can
only create a new tensor next let's look
at the api keras
what exactly is keras keras is a high
level deep learning api written in
python for easy implementation and
computation of neural networks keras is
an open source software library that
provides a tensorflow interface for
artificial neural networks keras acts as
an interface for the tensorflow library
which means that it runs on top of
tensorflow
up until version 2.3 keras supported
multiple back-ends
including tensorflow microsoft cognitive
toolkit
or cntk are theano and played ml
as of version 2.4 only tensorflow is
supported
as a version 2.4 only tensorflow is
supported
designed to help enable fast
experimentation with deep neural
networks in it focuses on being
user-friendly modular and extensible
keras is a high-level api of tensorflow
an approachable highly productive
interface for solving machine learning
problems with the focus on modern deep
learning it provides essential
abstractions and building blocks for
developing
and shipping machine learning solutions
with high iteration velocity keras does
not perform its own low level operations
such as tensor products and convolution
it relies on back end engines for that
even though keras supports multiple
back-end engines its primary back-end
engine is tensorflow and its primary
supporter is google which means that
keras acts as nothing more but a wrapper
class around tensorflow theano cntk
played ml or mxnet which are low level
apis next we will look at pi
what exactly is pytoch
pytoch is a low level api which is
developed by facebook for natural
language processing and computer vision
it is a more powerful version of numpy
it is an open source machine learning
library based on the torch library used
for applications such as computer vision
and natural language processing
primarily developed by facebook's ai
research lab it is free and open source
software released under the modified bsd
license although the python interface is
a more polished and the primary focus of
development pytorch also has a c plus
plus interface python is a widely liked
language because it is easy to
understand and write
pytorch emphasizes flexibility and
allows deep learning models to be
expressed in basic python pytorch is
mainly used for natural language
processing
and for computer vision
now let's move on to the differences
between tensorflow keras and pytorch
the first difference that we'll be
looking at is called level of api
there are two main types of apis a low
level api and a high level api api
stands for application programming
interface
a low-level application programming
interface is generally more detailed and
allows you to have more detailed control
to manipulate functions within them on
how to use and implement them
while a high level api is more generic
and simple and provides more
functionality with one command
statements than a lower level api
high level interfaces are comparatively
easier to learn and to implement the
models using them
they allow you to write code in a
shorter amount of time and to be less
involved with the details
in this case tensorflow is a high and
low level api
pure tensorflow is a low level api while
tensorflow wrapped in keras is a high
level api
keras in itself is a high level api
which uses multiple low level apis as a
back end and simplifies the operation of
these low-level apis
pi torch is a low level api
the next criteria that we'll be looking
at is speed
tensorflow is very fast and is used for
high performances
keras is slower as it works on top of
tensorflow not only does it have to wait
for tensorflow to finish implementation
it then starts its own implementation
meanwhile pi torch works at the same
speed as tensorflow as both of them are
both low level apis now keras is a
wrapper class for tensorflow and has
added abstraction functionalities on top
of tensorflow which make it slower than
tensorflow and pi touch in computation
speed both tensorflow and pytorch are
almost equal and in development speed
keras is faster as it has built-in
functionalities which can significantly
reduce your development time
the next difference is on the
architecture
tensorflow is not very easy to use and
even though it provides keras as a
framework that makes it work easier
tensorflow still has a very complex
architecture which is hard to use
meanwhile keras has a simpler
architecture and is easier to use it
provides a high level of abstraction
which makes implementation of programs
in keras significantly easier pie touch
on the other hand also has a complex
architecture and the readability is less
when compared to keras tensorflow uses
computational graphs which makes it very
complex and hard to interpret but it has
amazing computational ability across
platforms pie touch is a little hard for
beginners but is really good for
computer vision and deep learning
purposes
data sets and debugging
tensorflow works with large data sets
due to its high execution speed and
debugging is really hard in tensorflow
due to its complex nature
meanwhile keras only works with very
small data sets as its speed of
execution is low
programs do not require frequent
debugging in keras as they are
relatively simpler and pi torch can
manage high level tasks in higher
dimension data sets and is easier to
debug than both kiras and tensorflow
next we'll be looking at ease of
development
as we said before tensorflow works with
many
hard concepts such as computational
graphs and tensors which means that
writing code in tensorflow is very hard
it is generally used by people when they
are doing research work and really need
very specific functionalities
heroes on the other hand provides a high
level of abstraction which makes it very
easy to use it is best for people who
are just starting out with python and
machine learning pytorch is easier than
tensorflow but is still comparatively
hard than keras it is not
very easy to learn for beginners but is
significantly more powerful than just
plain keras ease of deployment
tensorflow is very easy to deploy as it
uses tensorflow serving tensorflow
serving is a flexible high performance
serving system for machine learning
models designed for production
environments tensorflow serving makes it
easy to deploy new algorithms and
experiments while keeping the same
server architecture and apis
tensorflow serving provides
out-of-the-box integration with
tensorflow models but can be easily
extended to serve other types of models
and data
in keras model deployment can be done
with either tensorflow serving or flask
which makes it relatively easy but not
as easy as you as it would be with
tensorflow and pytorch
pytorch uses pie torch mobile which
makes deployment easy but again for
tensorflow deployment is way easier as
tensorflow serving can update your
machine learning backend on the fly
without
the user even realizing
there's a growing need to execute ml
models on edge devices to reduce latency
preserve privacy and enable new
interactive use cases in the past
engineers used to train models
separately they would then go through a
multi-step error prone and often complex
process to train the models for
execution on a mobile device
the mobile runtime was often
significantly different from the
operations available during training
leading to inconsistent developer and
eventually user experience
all of these frictions have been removed
by pytorch mobile by allowing a seamless
process to go from training to
deployment by staying entirely within
the pytorch ecosystem it provides an
end-to-end workflow that simplifies the
research to production environment for
mobile devices
in addition it paves the way for privacy
preserving features via federated
learning techniques
at the end of the day the question that
really matters is which framework should
you use keras tensorflow or pytorch
now tensorflow has implemented various
levels of abstraction to make
implementation of deep learning and
neural networks easy this has also made
debugging easier keras is simple and
easy but not as fast as tensorflow it is
more user friendly than any other deep
learning api however and is easier to
learn for beginners
pytorch on the other hand is the
preferred deep learning api for teachers
but it is not as widely used in
production as tensorflow is it is faster
but it has lower gpu utilization
at the end of the day
the framework that we would suggest that
you use is tensorflow
why
while pi torch may have been the
preferred deep learning library for
researchers tensorflow is much more
widely used in day-to-day production
pytorch's ease of use combined with the
default ego execution mode for easier
debugging predestines it to be used for
fast hacky solutions and smaller scale
models
but tensorflow's extensions for
deployment on both servers and mobile
devices combined with the lack of python
overhead makes it the preferred option
for companies that work with deep
learning models
in addition the tensorflow board
visualization features offers a nice way
of showing the inner workings of your
model to say your customers
meanwhile between tensorflow and keras
the main difference isn't in performance
tensorflow is a bit faster due to less
overhead but also the level of control
you would like keras is much easier to
start with than plain tensorflow but if
you want to do something with keras that
doesn't come out of the box it will be
harder to implement that tensorflow on
the other hand allows you to create any
arbitrary computational graph providing
much more flexibility so if you're doing
more research type of work tensorflow is
the sure route to go due to the
flexibility that it provides if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
so we're going to dive right into what
is caras we'll also go all the way
through this into a couple of tutorials
because that's where you really learn a
lot is when you roll up your sleeves so
we talk about what is cross cross is a
high level deep learning api written in
python for easy implement implementation
of neural networks it uses deep learning
frameworks such as tensorflow pytorch
etc is back in to make computation
faster
and this is really nice because as a
programmer there is so much stuff out
there and it's evolving so fast
it can get confusing and having some
kind of high level order in there we can
actually view it and easily program
these different
neural networks
is really powerful it's really powerful
to have something out really quick
and also be able to start testing your
models and seeing where you're going
so crossworks by using complex deep
learning frameworks such as tensorflow
pytorch
ml played etc as a back end for fast
computation
while providing a user-friendly and easy
to learn front-end
and you can see here we have the cross
api specifications and under that you'd
have like tf cross for tensorflow thano
cross and so on and then you have your
tensorflow workflow that this is all
sitting on top of
and this is like i said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by tensorflow or whatever you know
underlying package you put in there and
this is really nice because you don't
have to
dig as deeply into the heavy end stuff
while still having a very robust package
you can get up and running rather
quickly
and it doesn't distract from the
processing time because all the heavy
lifting is done by packages like
tensorflow this is the organization on
top of it
so the working principle of cross
the working principle of keras is cross
uses computational graphs to express and
evaluate mathematical expressions
you can see here we put them in blue
they have the expression
expressing complex problems as a
combination of simple mathematical
operators where we have like the
percentage or in this case in python
that's usually your left your remainder
or multiplication
you might have the operator of x to the
power of 0.3 and it uses useful for
calculating derivatives by using
back propagation so if we're doing with
neural networks we send the error back
up to figure out how to change it
this makes it really easy to do that
without
really having not banging your head and
having to hand write everything it's
easier to implement distributed
computation and for solving complex
problems uh specify input and outputs
and make sure all nodes are connected
and so this is really nice as you come
in through is that as your layers are
going in there you can get some very
complicated
different setups nowadays which we'll
look at in just a second
and this just makes it really easy to
start spinning this stuff up and trying
out the different models so we look
across models across model we have a
sequential model
sequential model is a linear stack of
layers where the previous layer leads
into the next layer
and this if you've done anything else
even like the sk learn with their neural
networks and propagation and any of
these setups this should look familiar
you should have your input layer it goes
into your layer 1 layer 2 and then to
the output layer
and it's useful for a simple classifier
decoder models
and you can see down here we have the
model equals across sequential this is
the actual code you can see how easy it
is
we have a layer that's dense your layer
one
has an activation they're using the relu
in this particular example and then you
have your name layer 1 layer dense relu
name layer 2 and so forth
and they just feed right into each other
so it's really easy just to stack them
as you can see here and it automatically
takes care of everything else for you
and then there's a functional model
and this is really where things are at
this is new make sure you update your
cross or you'll find yourself running
this
doing the functional model you'll run
into an error code because this is a
fairly new release
and he uses multi input and multi output
model the complex model which forks into
two or more branches
and you can see here we have our image
inputs equals your cross input shape
equals 32 by 32 by 3
you have your dense layers dense 64
activation relu
this should look similar to what you
already saw before
but if you look at the graph on the
right it's going to be a lot easier to
see what's going on
you have two different inputs
and one way you could think of this is
maybe one of those is a small image and
one of those is a full-sized image
and
that feedback goes into you might feed
both of them into onenote because it's
looking for one thing
and then only into one node for the
other one and so you can start to get
kind of an idea that there's a lot of
use
for this kind of split and this kind of
setup
we have multiple information coming in
but the information is very different
even though it overlaps and you don't
want to send it through the same neural
network
and they're finding that this trains
faster and is also has a better result
depending on how you split the data and
how you fork the models coming down
and so in here we do have the two
complex uh models coming in
uh we have our image inputs which is a
32 by 32 by three or three channels or
four if you're having an alpha channel
uh
we have your dense your layers dense is
64 activation using the relu very common
x equals dense inputs x layers dense x64
activation equals relu x outputs equals
layers dense 10
x model equals cross model inputs equals
inputs outputs equals outputs name
equals minced model
uh so we add a little name on there and
again this is this kind of split here
this is setting us up to
have the input go into different areas
so if you're already looking at cars you
probably already have this answer what
are neural networks uh but it's always
good to get on the same page and for
those people who don't fully understand
neural networks to dive into them a
little bit or do a quick overview
neural networks are deep learning
algorithms modeled after the human brain
they use multiple neurons which are
mathematical operations to break down
and solve complex mathical problems
and so just like the neuron one neuron
fires in and it fires out to all these
other neurons or nodes as we call them
and eventually they all come down to
your output layer
and you can see here we have the really
standard graph input layer a hidden
layer and an output layer
one of the biggest parts of any data
processing is your data pre-processing
so we always have to touch base on that
with a neural network like many of these
models they're kind of uh when you first
start using them they're like a black
box you put your data in
you train it and you test it and see how
good it was
and you have to pre-process that data
because bad data in is bad outputs so in
data pre-processing we will create our
own data examples set with keras the
data consists of a clinical trial
conducted on 2100 patients ranging from
ages 13 to 100 with a the patients under
65 and the other half over 65 years of
age
we want to find the possibility of a
patient experiencing side effects due to
their age
and you can think of this in today's
world with covid
uh what's going to happen on there and
we're going to go ahead and do an
example of that in our
live hands-on like i said most of this
you really need to have hands-on to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda and open that up and
open up a jupiter notebook for doing the
python code in now if you're not
familiar with those you can use pretty
much any of your
setups i just like those for doing demos
and showing people especially
shareholders it really helps because
it's a nice visual so let me go and flip
over to our anaconda and the anaconda
has a lot of cool two tools they just
added data lore and ibm watson studio
cloud into the anaconda framework
but we'll be in the jupiter lab or
jupiter notebook i'm going to do jupiter
notebook for this because i use the lab
for like large projects with multiple
pieces because multiple tabs or the
notebook will work fine for what we're
doing
and this opens up in our browser window
because that's how jupiter dope so
jupiter
notebook is set to run
and we'll go under new
create a new python 3 and it creates an
untitled python we'll go ahead and give
this a title and we'll just call this a
cross
tutorial
and let's change that to capital there
we go i'm going to just rename that
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do
is uh
get some pre-processing tools involved
and so we need to go ahead and import
some stuff for that like our numpy do
some random number generation
um i mentioned sklearn or your site kit
if you're installing sklearn the sk
learn stuff it's a scikit you want to
look up
that should be a tool of anybody who is
doing data science if you're not if
you're not familiar with the sklearn
toolkit
it's huge but there's so many things in
there that we always go back to
and we want to go ahead and create some
train labels and train samples for
training our data
and then
just a note of what we're we're actually
doing in here let me go ahead and change
this this is kind of a fun thing you can
do we can change the code to markdown
and then markdown code is nice for doing
examples once you've already built this
uh our example data we're going to do
experimental
there we go
experimental drug was tested on 2 100
individuals between 13 to 100 years of
age
half the participants are under 65 and
95 percent of participants are under 65
experience no side effects well 95
percent of participants over 65
experience side effects so that's kind
of where we're starting at
and this is just a real quick example
because we're going to do another one
with a little bit more
complicated information
and so we want to go ahead and generate
our setup
so we want to do for i and range and we
want to go ahead and create if you look
here we have random integers
trading the labels append so we're just
creating some random data
let me go ahead and just run that
and so once we've created our random
data and if you if i mean you can
certainly ask for a copy of the code
from simplylearn they'll send you a copy
of this or you can
zoom in on the video and see how we went
ahead and did our train samples of pin
[Music]
and we're just using this i do this kind
of stuff all the time i was running a
thing on that had to do with errors
following a bell-shaped curve on
a standard distribution error
and so what do i do i generate the data
on a standard distribution error to see
what it looks like and how my code
processes it since that was the baseline
i was looking for in this we're just
doing uh generating random data for our
setup on here
and we could actually go in
print some of the data up let's just do
this print
we'll do train
samples and we'll just do the first
five pieces of data in there to see what
that looks like
and you can see the first five pieces of
data in our train samples is 49 85 41 68
19.
just random numbers generated in there
that's all that is and we generated
significantly more than that
um let's see 50 up here 1000 yeah so
there's 1 000 here 1 000 numbers we
generated and we could also if we wanted
to find that out we could do a quick
print the length of it
and
so or you can do a shape kind of thing
and if you're using numpy
although the link for this is just fine
and there we go it's actually 2100 like
we said in the demo setup in there
and then we want to go ahead and take
our labels oh that was our train labels
we also did samples didn't we
so we could also print
do the same thing
labels
and let's change this to
labels
and labels
and run that just to double check and
sure enough we have 2100 and they're
labeled one zero one zero one zero
i guess that's if they have symptoms or
not one symptoms zero none and so we
want to go ahead and take our train
labels and we'll convert it into a numpy
array
and the same thing with our samples
and let's go ahead and run that
and we also shuffle this is just a neat
feature you can do in numpy right here
put my drawing thing on which i didn't
have on earlier
i can take the data and i can shuffle it
so we have our so
it just randomizes it that's all that's
doing
we've already randomized it so it's kind
of an overkill it's not really necessary
but if you're doing a larger package
where the data is coming in and a lot of
times it's organized somehow and you
want to randomize it just to make sure
that
you know the input doesn't follow a
certain pattern
that might create a bias in your model
and we go ahead and create a scalar
the scalar range minimum max scalar
feature range zero to one
uh then we go ahead and scale the uh
scaled train samples so we're gonna go
ahead and fit and transform the data uh
so it's nice and scaled
and that is the age uh so you can see up
here we have 49 85 41. we're just moving
that so it's going to be between 0 and
1. and so this is true with any of your
neural networks
you really want to convert the data
to zero and one otherwise you create a
bias
so if you have like 100 creates a bias
versus
the math behind it gets really
complicated
if you actually start multiplying stuff
because a lot of multiplication addition
going on in there
that higher end value will eventually
multiply down and it will have a huge
bias as to how the model
fits it and then it will not fit as well
and then one of the fun things we can do
in jupiter notebook
is that if you have a variable you're
not doing anything with it it's the last
one on the line
it will automatically print
and we're just going to look at the
first five samples on here it's just
going to print the first five samples
and you can see here we go 0.9195.791
so everything's between 0 and 1.
and that just shows us that we scaled it
properly and it looks good
it really helps a lot to do these kind
of print ups halfway through
you never know what's going to go on
there
i don't know how many times i've gotten
down and found out that the data is sent
to me that i thought was scaled was not
and then i have to go back and track it
down and figure it out on there
uh so let's go ahead and create our
artificial neural network
and for doing that this is where we
start diving into tensorflow and cross
tensorflow
if you don't know the history of
tensorflow
it helps to jump into we'll just use
wikipedia
be careful don't quote wikipedia on
these things because you get in trouble
but it's a good place to start back in
2011 google brain built disbelief as a
proprietary machine learning setup
tensorflow became the open source for it
so tensorflow was a google product
and then it became
uh open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the de factos when it
comes for neural networks as far as
where we're at
so when you see the tensorflow setup
it's got like a huge following there are
some other setups like
the scikit under the sk learn has their
own little neural network
but the tensorflow is the most robust
one out there right now
and cross sitting on top of it makes it
a very powerful tool so we can leverage
both the cross
easiness in which we can build a
sequential setup
on top of tensorflow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of tensorflow
uh and then we have the rest of this is
all cross here from number two down uh
we're going to import from tensorflow
the cross
connection and then you have your
tensorflow cross models import
sequential it's a specific kind of model
we'll look at that in just a second if
you remember
from the files that means it goes from
one layer to the next layer to the next
layer there's no funky splits or
anything like that
and then we have from tensorflow across
layers we're going to import our
activation and our dense layer
and we have our optimizer atom
this is a big thing to be aware of how
you optimize uh your data when you first
do it atom's as good as any atom is
usually there's a number of optimizer
out there there's about uh there's a
couple of main ones but atom is usually
assigned to bigger data
it works fine usually the lower data
does it just fine but atom is probably
the mostly used but there are some more
out there and depending on what you're
doing with your layers your different
layers might have different activations
on them and then finally down here
you'll see
our setup where we want to go ahead and
use the metrics
and we're going to use the tensorflow
cross metrics
for categorical cross entropy
so we can see how everything performs
when we're done that's all that is a lot
of times you'll see us
go back and forth between tensorflow and
then scikit has a lot of really good
metrics also for measuring these things
again it's the end of the day you know
at the end of the story how good does
your model do and we'll go ahead and
load all that and then comes the
fun part um i actually like to spend
hours messing with these things
and
four lines of code you're like oh you're
gonna spend hours on four lines of code
um no we don't spend hours on four lines
of code that's not what we're talking
about when i say spend hours on four
lines of code
uh what we have here i'm gonna explain
that in just a second we have a model
and it's a sequential model if you
remember correctly we mentioned the
sequential up here where it goes from
one layer to the next
and our first layer is going to be our
input
it's going to be what they call dents
which is um usually it's just dense and
then you have your input and your
activation
how many units are coming in we have 16
what's the shape
what's the activation and this is where
it gets interesting um because we have
in here
uh relu
on two of these and softmax activation
on one of these
there are so many different options for
what these mean
and how they function how does the relu
how does the soft max function
and they do a lot of different things
we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
these different activations
and just
some of it is just
almost like you're playing with it
like an artist you start getting a fill
for like a inverse tangent activation or
the 10 h activation
takes up a huge processing amount
so you don't see it a lot
yet
it comes up with a better solution
especially when you're doing uh when
you're analyzing word documents and
you're tokenizing the words
and so you'll see this shift from one to
the other because you're both trying to
build a better model
and if you're working on a huge data set
you'll crash the system it'll just take
too long to process
and then you see things like soft max
softmax
generates an interesting
setup
where a lot of these when you talk about
rayleigh oops let me do this
rayleigh there we go relu has
a setup where if it's less than zero
it's zero and then it goes up
and then you might have what they call
lazy
setup where it has a slight negative to
it so that the errors can translate
better same thing with softmax it has a
slight laziness to it so that errors
translate better all these little
details
make a huge difference on your model
so one of the really cool things about
data science that i like is you build
your
what they call you build to fail and
it's an interesting
design setup oops i forgot the end of my
code here
the concept to build a file is you want
the model as a whole to work so you can
test your model out
so that you can do
you can get to the end and you can do
your let's see where was it
over shot down here
you can test your test out the quality
of your setup on there
and
see where did i do my tensorflow oh here
we go it was right above me there we go
we start doing your cross entropy and
stuff like that is you need a full
functional set of code so that when you
run it
you can then test your model out and say
hey it's either this model works better
than this model and this is why
and then you can start swapping in these
models and so when i say spend a huge
amount of time on pre-processing data
it's probably 80 of your programming
time
um
well between those two it's like 80 20.
you'll spend a lot of time on the models
once you get the model down once you get
the whole code and the flow down
set
depending on your data your models get
more and more robust as you start
experimenting with different inputs
different data streams and all kinds of
things and we can do a simple model
summary here
here's our sequential here's a layer
output a parameter
this is one of the nice things about
cross is you just you can see right here
here's our sequential one model boom
boom boom boom everything's set and
clear and easy to read
so once we have our model built uh the
next thing we're going to want to do is
we're going to go ahead and train that
model
and so the next step is of course model
training
and when we come in here
this a lot of times it's just paired
with the model because it's so
straightforward it's nice to
print out the model set up so you can
have a tracking
but here's our model
the keyword in cross is compile
optimizer atom learning rate another
term right there that we're just
skipping right over
that really becomes the meat of um
the setup is your learning rate uh so
whoops i forgot that i had an arrow but
i'll just underline
it a lot of times the learning rate set
to .0
set to 0.01 uh depending on what you're
doing
this learning rate
can overfit and underfit
so you'd want to look up
i know we have a number of tutorials out
on overfitting and under fitting that
are really worth reading once you get to
that point and understanding and we have
our loss
sparse categorical cross entropy
so this is going to tell kaross how far
to go until it stops
and then we're looking for metrics of
accuracy so we'll go ahead and run that
and now that we've compiled our model
we want to go ahead and
run it fit it so here's our model fit
we have our scaled train samples
our train labels our validation split
in this case we're going to use 10
percent of the data for validation
batch size another number you kind of
play with not a huge difference as far
as how it works
but it does affect how long it takes to
run and it can also affect the bias a
little bit
most of the time though a batch size is
between 10 to 100
depending on just how much data you're
processing in there we want to go ahead
and shuffle it we're going to go through
30 epics
and
put the verb rose of two let me just go
ahead and run this
and you can see right here here's our
epic here's our training
here's our loss now if you remember
correctly up here we set the loss let's
see where was it
compiled our data
there we go loss uh so it's looking at
the sparse categorical cross entropy
this tells us that as it goes how how
how much
how how much does the
error go down
is the best way to look at that and you
can see here the lower the number the
better it just keeps going down
and vice versa accuracy we want let's
see where's my accuracy
value accuracy at the end
and you can see 0.619 0.69 0.74 it's
going up we want the accuracy would be
ideal if it made it all the way to 1
but we also the loss is more important
because
it's a balance
you can have 100 accuracy and your model
doesn't work because it's over fitted
again you won't look up overfitting and
underfitting models
and we went ahead and went through
30 epics it's always fun to kind of
watch your code going
um to be honest i
usually uh
the first time i run it i'm like oh
that's cool i get to see what it does
and after the second time of running it
i'm like i like to just not see that and
you can repress those of course in your
code
repress the warnings in the printing
and so the next step is going to be
building a test set and predicting it
now
so here we go we want to go ahead and
build our test set and we have just like
we did our training set
a lot of times you just split your your
initial set up
but we'll go ahead and do a separate set
on here
and this is just what we did above
there's no difference as far as
the randomness that we're using to build
this set on here
the only difference is that
we already
did our scalar up here well it doesn't
matter because the the data is going to
be across the same thing but this should
just be just transformed down here
instead of fit transform
because you don't want to refit your
data
on your testing data
there we go now we're just transforming
it because you never want to transform
the test data
easy to mistake to make especially on an
example like this where we're not doing
you know we're randomizing the data
anyway so it doesn't matter too much
because we're not expecting something
weird
and then we went ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model as we take our model we
predict
and we're going to do here's our x scale
data batch size 10 verbose
and now we have our predictions in here
and we could go ahead and do a
oh we'll print
predictions
and then i guess i could just put down
predictions in five so we can look at
the first five of the predictions
and what we have here is we have our
age
and uh the prediction on this age versus
what is what we think it's going to be
but what we think is going to they're
going to have
symptoms or not
and the first thing we notice is that's
hard to read because we really want a
yes no answer
so we'll go ahead and just
round off the predictions
using the arg max
the numpy arg max for prediction so it
just goes to 001
and
if you remember this is a jupiter
notebook so i don't have to put the
print i can just put in
rounded predictions and we'll just do
the first five
and you can see here zero one zero zero
zero so that's what the predictions are
that we have coming out of this
is no symptoms symptoms no symptoms
symptoms
no symptoms
and just as we were talking about at the
beginning we want to go ahead and
take a look at this there we go
confusion matrix is for accuracy check
most important part
when you get down to the end of the
story how accurate is your model before
you go and play with the model and see
if you can get a better accuracy out of
it and for this we'll go ahead and use
the site kit
the sk learn metrics site kit being
where that comes from
import confusion matrix
some iteration tools and of course a
nice matte plot library
that makes a big difference so it's
always nice to
we have a nice graph to look at a
picture is worth a thousand words
and then we'll go ahead and call it cm
for confusion matrix why true equals
test labels why predict rounded
predictions
and we'll go ahead and load in our cm
and i'm not going to spend too much time
on the plotting
going over the different plotting code
you can spend
like whole we have whole tutorials on
how to do your different plotting on
there
but we do have here is we're gonna do a
plot confusion matrix there's our cm our
classes normalize false title confusion
matrix
c map is going to be in blues
and you can see here we have uh to the
nearest c map titles all the different
pieces whether you put tick marks or not
the marks the classes the color bar
so a lot of different information on
here as far as how we're doing the
printing of the of the confusion matrix
you can also just dump the confusion
matrix into a seaborn and real quick get
an output
it's worth knowing how to do all this
when you're doing a presentation to the
shareholders
you don't want to do this on the fly you
want to take the time to make it look
really nice like our guys in the back
did and let's go ahead and do this
forgot to put together our cm plot
labels
we'll go ahead and run that
and then we'll go ahead and call the
little the definition
for our mapping
and you can see here plot confusion
matrix that's our the little script we
just wrote and we're going to dump our
data into it
so our confusion matrix
our classes
title confusion matrix and let's just go
ahead and run that
and you can see here we have our basic
setup
no side effects 195
had side effects 200
no side effects that had side effects so
we predicted the 10 of them
who actually had side effects and that's
pretty good i mean i don't know about
you but you know that's five percent
error on this and this is because
there's 200 here that's where i get five
percent is uh divide these both by by
two and you get five out of a hundred uh
you can do the same kind of math up here
not as quick on the fly because it's 15
and 195 not an easily rounded number but
you can see here where they have 15
people
who predicted to have no
with the no side effects but had side
effects
kind of set up on there and these
confusion matrix are so important at the
end of the day
this is really where where you show uh
whatever you're working on comes up and
you can actually show them hey this is
how good we are or not how messed up it
is
so this was a uh i spent a lot of time
on some of the parts uh but you can see
here is really simple uh we did the
random generation of data but when we
actually built the model coming up here
uh here's our model summary
and we just have the layers on here that
we built with our model on this and then
we went ahead and trained it and ran the
prediction
now we can get a lot more complicated uh
let me flip back on over here because
we're going to do another uh demo
so that was our basic introduction to it
we talked about the uh oops there we go
okay so implementing a neural network
with keras after creating our samples
and labels we need to create our cross
neural network model we will be working
with a sequential model which has three
layers and this is what we did we had
our input layer our hidden layers and
our output layers and you can see the
input layer coming in
was the age factor we had our hidden
layer and then we had the output are you
going to have symptoms or not
so we're going to go ahead and go with
something a little bit more complicated
training our model is a two-step process
we first compile our model and then we
train it in our training data set
so we have compiling compiling converts
the code into a form of understandable
by machine
we use the atom in the last example a
gradient descent algorithm to optimize a
model and then we trained our model
which means it let it
learn on training data
and i actually had a little backwards
there but this is what we just did is we
if you remember from our code we just
had let me go back here
here's our model that we created
summarized
we come down here and we compile it
so it tells it hey we're ready to build
this model and use it
and then we train it this is the part
where we go ahead and fit our model and
and put that information in here and it
goes through the training on there
and of course we scaled the data which
was really important to do and then you
saw we did the creating a confusion
matrix with keras
as we are performing classifications on
our data we need a confusion matrix to
check the results a confusion matrix
breaks down the various
misclassifications as well as correct
classifications to get the accuracy
and so you can see here this is what we
did with the true positive false
positive true negative false negative
and that is what we went over let me
just scroll down here
on the end we printed it out and you see
we have a nice printout of our confusion
matrix
with the true positive false positive
false negative true negative
so the blue ones uh we want those to be
the biggest numbers because those are
the better side and then
we have our false predictions on here
as far as this one so i had no side
effects but we predicted
let's see no side effects predicting
side effects and vice versa if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now uh saving and loading models with
karas we're going to dive into a more
complicated demo
and you can say oh that was a lot of
complication before well if you broke it
down we randomized some data we created
the
cross setup we compiled it we trained it
we predicted and we ran our matrix
so we're going to dive into something a
lot a little bit more fun is we're going
to do a face mask detection with cross
so we're going to build a cross model to
check if a person is wearing a mask or
not in real time and this might be
important if you're at the front of a
store this is something today which is
might be very useful as far as some of
our you know making sure people are safe
and so we're going to look at mask and
no mask and let's start with a little
bit on the data
and so in my data i have with a mask you
can see they just have a number of
images showing the people in masks and
again
if you want some of this information
contact simply learn and they can send
you some of the information as far as
people with and without masks so you can
try it on your own and this is just such
a wonderful example of this setup on
here
so before i dive into the mass detection
talk about being in the current with uh
kovid and seeing if people are wearing
masks
this particular example i had to go
ahead and update to a python 3.8 version
uh it might run in a three seven i'm not
sure i kind of skipped three seven and
installed three eight
uh so i'll be running in a three python
three eight
and then you also wanna make sure your
tensorflow is up to date
because the um they call functional
uh layers with that's where they split
if you remember correctly from back
oh let's take a look at this
remember from here the functional model
and a functional layer
allows us to feed in the different
layers into different you know different
nodes into different layers and split
them a very powerful tool
very popular right now in the edge of
where things are with neural networks
and creating a better model so i've
upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and
go through
our next example which includes
multiple layers
programming it to recognize whether
someone wears a mask or not and then
saving that model so we can use it in
real time so we're actually almost a
full
um end-to-end development of a product
here uh of course this is a very
simplified version and it'd be a lot
more to it you'd also have to do like
recognizing whether it's someone's face
or not
all kinds of other things go into this
so let's go ahead and jump into that
code
and we'll open up a new python three
oops python3
it's working on it there we go
um and then we want to go ahead and
train our mask we'll just call this
train mask
and we want to go ahead and train mask
and save it
so it's it's uh
save mask train mask detection
not to be confused with masking data a
little bit different we're actually
talking about a physical mask on your
face
and then from the cross standpoint we've
got a lot of imports to do here
and i'm not going to dig too deep on the
imports
we're just going to go ahead and notice
a few of them
so we have in here
alt d there we go
i have something to draw with a little
bit here
we have our
image processing
and the image processing right here let
me underline that
deals with how do we bring images in
because most images
are like a
square grid and then each value in there
has three values for the three different
colors
cross and tensorflow do a really good
job of working with that so you don't
have to do all the heavy listening and
figuring out what's going to go on
uh and we have the mobile net average
pooling 2d
this again is
how do we deal with the images and
pulling them
dropout's a cool thing worth looking up
if you haven't when you as you get more
and more into cross and tensorflow uh it
will auto drop out certain nodes that
way you'll get a better um the notes
just kind of die
and they find that they actually create
more of a bias and help
and they also add processing time so
they remove them
um and then we have our flatten that's
where you take that huge array with the
three different colors and you find a
way to flatten it so it's just a
one-dimensional array instead of a two
by two by three
uh dense input we did that in the other
one so that should look a little
familiar
oops there we go our input our model
again these are things we had on the
last one
here's our optimizer with our atom
we have some pre-processing on the input
that goes along with bringing the data
in
more pre-processing with image to array
loading the image
this stuff is so nice it looks like a
lot of works you have to import all
these different modules in here but the
truth is is it does everything for you
you're not doing a lot of pre-processing
you're letting the software do the
pre-processing
and we're going to be working with the
setting something to categorical
again that's just a conversion from a
number to a category 0 1 doesn't really
mean anything it's like true false
label binarizer the same thing uh we're
changing our labels around
and then there's our train test split
classification report um our
im utilities let me just go ahead and
scroll down here a notch for these this
is something a little different going on
down here this is not part of the
tensorflow or the sklearn this is the
site kit set up in tensorflow above
the path this is part of
opencv
and we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the opencv so if you want
to know more about opencv you'll get a
glance on it in
this software especially the second
piece when we reload up the data and
hook it up to a video camera we're going
to do that
on this round
but this is part of the open cv thing
you'll see cv2 is usually how that's
referenced
but the im utilities has to do with how
do you rotate pictures around and stuff
like that
and resize them and then the matte plot
library for plotting because it's nice
to have a graph tells us how good we're
doing and then of course our numpy
numbers array and just the straight os
access wow so that was a lot of imports
uh like i said i'm not going to spend i
spent a little time going through them
but we didn't want to go too much into
them
and then i'm going to create
some variables that we need to go ahead
and initialize
we have the learning rate number of
epochs to train for and the batch size
and if you remember correctly we talked
about the learning rate
to the negative 4.0001
a lot of times it's 0.001 or 0.001
usually it's in that
variation depending on what you're doing
and how many epochs and they kind of
play with the epics
the epics is how many times we're going
to go through all the data
now i have it as two
the actual setup is for 20 and 20 works
great the reason i have it for two is it
takes a long time to process
one of the downsides of jupiter
is that jupiter isolates it to a single
kernel so even though i'm on an eight
core processor
with 16 dedicated threads only one
thread is running on this no matter what
so it doesn't matter
so it takes a lot longer to run even
though
tensorflow really scales up nicely and
the batch size is how many pictures do
we load at once in process
again those are numbers you have to
learn to play with depending on your
data and what's coming in and the last
thing we want to go ahead and do is
there's a directory with a data set
we're going to run
and this just has images of mass and not
masks
and if we go in here you'll see data set
and then you have pictures with mass
they're just images of people with mass
on their face
uh and then we have the opposite and go
back up here
without masks so it's pretty
straightforward they look kind of askew
because they tried to format them into
very similar uh setup on there so
they're they're
mostly squares you'll see some that are
slightly different on here
and that's kind of important thing to do
on a lot of these data sets
get them as close as you can to each
other and we'll we actually will run in
the in this processing of images up here
and the cross layers and importing and
dealing with images it does such a
wonderful job of converting these that a
lot of it we don't have to do a whole
lot with
so you have a couple things going on
there
and so we're now going to be this is now
loading the
images and let me see
and we'll go ahead and create data and
labels here's our
here's the features going in which is
going to be our pictures and our labels
going out
and then for categories in our list
directory directory and if you remember
i just flashed that at you it had uh
face mask or or no face mask those are
the two options
and we're just going to load into that
we're going to append the image itself
and the labels so we'll just create a
huge array
and you can see right now this could be
an issue if you had more data at some
point
thankfully i have a 32 gig hard drive or
ram
even that
you could do with a lot less of that
probably under 16 or even eight gigs
would easily load all this stuff
and there's a conversion going on in
here i told you about how we are going
to convert
the size of the image so it resizes all
the images that way our data is all
identical the way it comes in
and you can see here with our labels we
have without mask without mask without
mask
the other one would be with mask those
are the two that we have going in there
and then we need to change it to the one
not hot encoding
and this is going to take our
up here we had was it labels and data
we want the labels to be categorical so
we're going to take labels and change it
to categorical and our labels then equal
a categorical list
we'll run that and again if we do
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10. let's do the last 10 just
because
minus 10 to the end there we go
just so we can see where the other side
looks like we now have one that means
they have a mask 1 0 1 0 zero so on
uh one being they have a mask and zero
no mask
and if we did this in reverse
i just realized that this might not make
sense if you've never done this before
let me run this
zero one
so zero
is uh do they have a mask on zero do
they not have a mask on one so this is
the same as what we saw up here without
mask one equals
the second value is without mass so with
mass without mask
and that's just a with any of your data
processing
we can't really zero if you have a zero
one output
uh
it causes issues as far as training and
setting it up so we always want to use a
one hot encoder if the values are not
actual uh linear value or regression
values or not actual numbers
if they represent a thing
and so now we need to go ahead and do
our train x test x train y test y
train split test data
and we'll go ahead and make sure it's
going to be random and we'll take 20 of
it for testing and the rest for
setting it up as far as training their
model
this is something that's become so cool
when they're training these set
they realize we can augment the data
what does augment mean
well if i rotate the data around and i
zoom in i zoom out i rotate it
share it a little bit flip it
horizontally
fill mode as they do all these different
things to the data it
is able to it's kind of like increasing
the number of samples i have
so if i have all these perfect samples
what happens when we only have part of
the face or the face is tilted sideways
or
all those little shifts cause a problem
if you're doing just a standard set of
data so we're going to create an augment
in our image data generator
which is going to rotate zoom and do all
kinds of cool thing and this is worth
looking up this image data generator and
all the different features it has
a lot of times i'll the first time
through my models i'll leave that out
because i want to make sure there's a
thing we call build to fail which is
just cool to know
you build the whole process and then you
start adding these different things in
so that you can better train your model
and so we go and run this and then we're
going to load
and then we need to go ahead and you
probably would have gotten an error if
you hadn't put this piece in right here
um i haven't run it myself because the
guys in the back did this
we take our base model and one of the
things we want to do is we want to do a
mobile net v2
and this we this is a big thing right
here include the top equals false
a lot of data comes in with a label on
the top row uh so we want to make sure
that that is not the case
uh and then the construction of the head
of the model that will be placed on the
top of the base model
we want to go ahead and set that up
and you'll see a warning here i'm kind
of ignoring the warning because it has
to do with the
size of the pictures and the weights for
input shape
so they'll switch things to defaults
just saying hey we're going to auto
shape some of this stuff for you you
should be aware that with this kind of
imagery we're already augmenting it by
moving it around and flipping it and
doing all kinds of things to it
so that's not a bad thing in this but
another data it might be if you're
working in a different domain
and so we're going to go back here and
we're going to have we have our base
model we're going to do our head model
equals our base model output
and what we got here is we have an
average pooling 2d pool size 77 head
model
head model flattened
so we're flattening the data
so this is all processing and flattening
the images and the pooling has to do
with some of the ways it can process
some of the data we'll look at that a
little bit when we get down to the lower
levels processing it
and then we have our dents we've already
talked a little bit about a dents just
what you think about and then the head
model has a drop out
of 0.5
what we can do with a dropout
the dropout says that we're going to
drop out a certain amount of nodes while
training
so when you actually use the model
it will use all the nodes but this drops
certain ones out and it helps
stop biases from performing so it's
really a cool feature in here they
discovered this a while back
uh we have another dense mode and this
time we're using soft max activation
lots of different activation options
here softmax is a real popular one for a
lot of things
and so is relu
and you know there's we could do a whole
talk on activation formulas uh and why
what their different uses are and how
they work
when you first start out you'll you'll
use mostly the relu and the softmax for
a lot of them
just because they're some of the basic
setups it's a good place to start
and then we have our model equals model
inputs equals base model dot input
outputs equals head model so again we're
still building our model here we'll go
ahead and run that
and then we're going to loop over all
the layers in the base model and freeze
them so they will not be updated during
the first training process
so for layer and base model layers
layers dot trainable equals false
a lot of times when you go through your
data
you want to kind of jump in part way
through
i
i'm not sure why in the back they did
this for this particular example
but i do this a lot when i'm working
with series and specifically in stock
data i wanted to iterate through the
first set of 30 data before it does
anything
i would have to look deeper to see why
they froze it on this particular one
and then we're going to compile our
model
so compiling the model atom
init layer decay
initial learning rate over epics
and we go ahead and compile our loss is
going to be the binary cross entropy
which we'll have that print out
optimizer for opt metrics is accuracy
same thing we had before not a huge jump
as far as
the previous code
and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model
so train the head of the network print
info training head run
now i skipped a little time because
you'll see the run time here is at 80
seconds per epic takes a couple minutes
for it to get through on a single kernel
one of the things i want you to notice
on here while we're well it's finishing
the processing
is that we have up here our augment
going on so
anytime the train x and trading y go in
there's some randomness going on there
and it's jiggling it around what's going
into our setup
uh of course we're batch sizing it uh so
it's going through whatever we set for
the batch values how many we process at
a time
and then we have the steps per epic
the train x the batch size validation
data here's our
test x and test y where we're sending
that in
and this again it's validation
one of the important things to know
about validation is
are
when both our training data and our test
data have about the same accuracy that's
when you want to stop that means that
our model isn't biased
if you have a higher accuracy on your
testing
you know you've trained it and your
accuracy is higher on your actual test
data then something in there is probably
uh has a bias and it's over fitted
so that's what this is really about
right here with the validation data and
validation steps
so it looks like it's let me go ahead
and see if it's done processing looks
like we've gone ahead and gone through
two epochs again you could run this
through about 20
with this amount of data and it would
give you a nice refined model at the end
we're going to stop at 2 because i
really don't want to sit around all
afternoon and i'm running this on a
single thread
so now that we've done this we're going
to need to evaluate
our model and see how good it is and to
do that we need to go ahead and make our
predictions
these are predictions on our test x
to see what it thinks are going to be
so now it's going to be evaluating the
network and then we go ahead and go down
here and we will need to
turn the index in because remember it's
it's either zero or one it's a
zero one zero one so you have two
outputs uh not wearing uh wearing a mask
not wearing a mask
and so we need to go ahead and take that
argument at the end and change those
predictions to a
0 or 1 coming out
and then
to finish that off we want to go ahead
and let me just put this right in here
and do it all in one shot we want to
show a nicely formatted classification
report so we can see what that looks
like on here
and there we have it we have our
precision uh it's 97 with the mask
there's our f1 score support without a
mass 97 percent
so that's pretty high
set up on there you know you three
people are going to sneak into the store
who
are without a mask and
thinks they have a mask and there's
going to be three people with a mask
that's going to flag the person at the
front to go oh hey look at this person
you might not have a mask
that's if i guess it's just set up in
front of a store
so there you have it and of course one
of the other cool things about this is
if someone's walking in to the store and
you take multiple pictures of them
you know this is just an it would be a
way of flagging and then you can take
that average of those pictures and make
sure they match or don't match if you're
on the back end and this is an important
step because we're gonna this is just
cool i love doing this stuff uh so we're
gonna go ahead and take our model and
we're gonna save it uh so model save
mass detector.model we're gonna give it
a name
we're gonna save the format
in this case we're going to use the h5
format
and so this model we just programmed has
just been saved
so now i can load it up into say another
program what's cool about this is let's
say i want to have somebody work on the
other part of the program well i just
save the model they upload the model now
they can use it for whatever and then if
i get more information
and we start working with that at some
point
i might want to update this model and
make a better model and this is true of
so many things where i take this model
and maybe i'm running a prediction on
making money for a company and as my
model gets better
i want to keep updating it and then it's
really easy just to push that out to the
actual end user
and here we have a nice graph you can
see the training loss and accuracy as we
go through the epics
we only did the you know only shows just
the one epic coming in here but you can
see right here as the uh
value loss train accuracy and value
accuracy
starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is a convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're um
i know when i work in the
psy kit with sk learn neural networks
this is what they're talking about a
convergence is our
loss and our accuracy come together and
also up here and this is why i'd run it
more than just two epics as you can see
they still haven't converged all the way
so that would be a cue for me to keep
going
but what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and create a new
python 3
program
and we just did our train mask so now
we're going to go ahead and import that
and use it and show you in a live action
get a view of both myself in the
afternoon along with my background of an
office which is in the middle still of
reconstruction for another month
and we'll call this a mask
detector
and then we're going to grab a bunch of
a few items coming in
we have our
mobile net v2 import pre-processing
input because we're still going to need
that
we still have our tensorflow image to
array we have our load model that's
where most of this stuff is going on
this is our cv2 or opencv again i'm not
going to dig too deep into that we're
going to flash a little opencv code at
you
and we actually have a tutorial on that
coming out
our numpy array our im utilities which
is part of the opencv or cv2 setup
and then we have of course time and just
our operating system so those are the
things we're going to go ahead and set
up on here
and then we're going to create
this takes just a moment
our module here which is going to do all
the heavy lifting
so we're going to detect and predict the
mask we have frame face net mass net
these are going to be generated by our
open cv we have our frame coming in and
then we want to go ahead and create a
mask around the face it's going to try
to detect the face
and then set that up so we know
what we're going to be processing
through our model
and then there's a frame shape here this
is just our height versus width that's
all hw stands for
they've called it blob which is a cv2
dnn blob form image frame
so this is reformatting this frame
that's going to be coming in literally
from my camera and we'll show you that
in a minute that little piece of code
that shoots that in here
and we're going to pass the blob through
the network and obtain the face
detections
so face net dot set import blob
detections face net forward
print detections shape
so this is this is what's going on here
this is that model we just created we're
going to send that in there and i'll
show you in a second where that is but
it's going to be under face net
uh and then we go ahead and initialize
our list of faces their corresponding
locations and the list of predictions
from our face mask network
we're going to loop over the detections
and this is a little bit more work than
you think
as far as looking for different faces
whatever the view of a crowd of faces
um so we're looping through the
detections and the shapes going through
here
and probability associated with the
detection uh here's our confidence of
detections
we're going to filter out weak detection
by ensuring the confidence is greater
than the minimum confidence
so we've said it remember 0 to 1 so 0.5
would be our minimum confidence probably
is pretty good
[Music]
and then we're going to put in compute
bounding boxes for the object if i'm
zipping through this it's because we're
going to do an opencv and i really want
to stick to just the cross part
and so i'm just kind of jumping through
all this code you can get a copy of this
code from simply learn and take it apart
or look for the opencv coming out
and we'll create a box the box sets it
around the image
ensure the bounding boxes fall within
the dimensions of the frame
so we create a box around what's going
to what we hope is going to be the face
extract the face roi convert it from bgr
to rgb channel
again this is an open cv issue not
really an issue but it has to do with
the order i don't know how many times
i've forgotten to check the order colors
when working with opencv
because there's all kinds of fun things
when red becomes blue
and blue becomes red
uh and we're gonna go ahead and resize
it process it frame it
face frame
setup again the face the cbt color we're
going to convert it
we're going to resize it
image to array pre-process the input
pin the face locate face start x dart y
and x boy that was just a huge amount
and i skipped over a ton of it but the
bottom line is we're building a box
around the face
and that box because the opencv does a
decent job of finding the face and that
box is going to go in there and see hey
does this person have a mask on it
and so that's what that's what all this
is doing on here and then finally we get
down to this where it says predictions
equals mass net dot predict faces batch
size 32
so these different images where we're
guessing where the face is are then
going to go through and
generate an array of faces if you will
and we're going to look through and say
does this face have a mask on it and
that's what's going right here is our
prediction that's the big thing that
we're working for
and then we return the locations and the
predictions the location just tells
where on the picture it is
and then the prediction tells us what it
is is it a mask or is it not a mask
all right so we've loaded that all up
so we're going to load our serialized
face detector model from disk
and we have our the path that it was
saved in obviously you're gonna put in a
different path depending on where you
have it or however you want to do it and
how you saved it on the last one where
we trained it
uh and then we have our weights path um
and so finally our face net here it is
equals cb2.dnn.readnet
prototext path weights path and we're
going to load that up on here so let me
go ahead and run that
and then we also need to i'll just put
it right down here i always hate
separating these things in there
um and then we're going to load the
actual mass detector model from disk
this is the the model that we saved so
let's go ahead and run that on there
also so this is pulling on all the
different pieces we need for our model
and then the next part is we're going to
create open up our video
and this is just kind of fun because
it's all part of the opencv
the video set up
and we just put this all in as one
there we go
uh so we're going to go ahead and open
up our video we're going to start it and
we're going to run it until we're done
and this is where we get some real like
kind of live action stuff which is fun
this is what i like working about with
images and videos
is that when you start working with
images and videos it's all like right
there in front of you it's visual and
you can see what's going on
so we're going to start our video
streaming this is grabbing our video
stream source zero start
that means it's grabbing my main camera
i have hooked up
um
and then you know starting video you're
gonna print it out
here's our video source equals zero
start loop over the frames from the
video stream
oops a little redundancy there
let me close
i'll just leave it that's how they
headed in the code so
so while true we're going to grab the
frame from the threaded video stream and
resize it to have the maximum width of
400 pixels so here's our frame we're
going to read it
from our visual
stream
we're going to resize it
and then we have we're returning
remember we return from the our
procedure the location and the
prediction so detect and predict mask
we're sending it the frame
we're sending it the face net and the
mass net so we're sending all the
different pieces that say this is what's
going through on here
and then it returns our location of
predictions and then for our box
and predictions in the location and
predictions
and the boxes is again this is an open
cv set that says hey this is a box
coming in from the location
because you have the two different
points on there
and then we're going to unpack the box
and predictions and we're going to go
ahead and do mask without a mask equals
prediction
we're going to create our label
no mask and create color if the label
equals mask l0225
and you know it's going to make a lot
more sense when i hit the run button
here
but we have the probability of the label
we're going to display the label and
bounding box rectangle in the output
frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
show the output from the frame cv2 i am
show frame frame and then the key equals
cp2 weight key one we're just going to
wait till the next one comes through
from our feed
and we're going to do this until we hit
the stop button pretty much
so you're ready for this to see if it
works we've distributed our our model
we've loaded it up into our distributed
code here we've got a hooked into our
camera and we're going to go ahead and
run it
and there it goes it's going to be
running and we can see the data coming
down here and we're waiting for the
pop-up
and there i am in my office with my
funky headset on
uh
and you can see in the background my
unfinished wall and it says up here no
mask oh no i don't have a mask on
i wonder if i cover my mouth
what would happen
you can see my no mask
goes down a little bit i wish i brought
a mask into my office it's up at the
house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98 percent
chance that i don't have a mask on and
it's true i don't have a mask on right
now and this could be distributed this
is actually an excellent little piece of
script that you can start you know you
install somewhere on a video feed on on
a security camera or something and then
you'd have this really neat setup saying
hey do you have a mask on when you enter
a store or
public transportation or whatever it is
where they're required to wear a mask
let me go ahead and stop that
now if you want a copy of this code
definitely give us a hauler we will be
going into opencv in another one so i
skipped a lot of the opencv
code in here as far as going into detail
really focusing on the cross
saving the model uploading the model and
then processing a streaming video
through it so you can see it that the
model works we actually have this
working model that hooks into the video
camera
which is just pretty cool and a lot of
fun
so i told you we're going to dive in and
really roll up our sleeve and do a lot
of coding today we did the basic uh
demo up above for just pulling in a
cross and then we went into a cross
model
where we pulled in data to see whether
someone was wearing a mask or not so
very useful in today's world as far as a
fully running application sequential
models in keras
so what is cross
cross is a high level python deep
learning api
which is used for easy implementation of
neural networks it has multiple
low-level backends like tensorflow
thano
pie torch etc which are used for fast
computation
so you can think of this as cross being
almost its own little programming
language
and then it sits on neural networks in
this case uh the ones listed were
tensorflow thano and pytorch which can
all integrate with the cross model
this makes it very diverse and also
makes it very easy to use and switch
around with different things
cross is very
user friendly as far as neural network
software goes as a high level api
computational graphs
so computational graphs are really the
heart and soul of neural networks
we talk about a computational graph
they are a visual representation of
expressing and evaluating mathematical
equations
the nodes and data flow in a graph
correspond to mathematical operations
and variables
you'll hear a lot some of the terms you
might hear are node and edge the edge
being the data flow in this case
it could also represent an actual value
they have
oh i think in spark they have a graph x
which works just on computing edges
there's all kinds of stuff that has
evolved from computational graphs we're
focusing just on cross and on neural
networks so we're not going to go into
great detail on everything a
computational graph does it is the core
component of a neural network is what's
important to know on this
so cross offers a python user-friendly
front-end while maintain a strong
computation power by using a low-level
api
like tensorflow pi torch etc which use
computational graphs as a back end
so one this allows for abstraction of
complex problems while specifying
control flow
if you've ever looked at some of the
backend or the original versions of
tensorflow
it's really a nightmare you have all
these different settings you have to put
in there and create
it's a lot a lot of back-end programming
this is like the old computers when you
had to
tell it how to dispose of a variable and
how to properly re-allocate the memory
for use
all that is covered nowadays in our
higher level programming well this is
the same thing with cross is it covers a
lot of this stuff and does things for
you that you could spend hours on just
trying to figure out
it's useful for calculating derivatives
by using back propagation
we're definitely not going to teach a
class on derivatives
in this little video
but understanding a derivative is the
rate of change so if you have a
particular function you're using in your
neural network
a lot of them is just simple
y equals mx plus b
your euclidean geometry where you just
have a simple slope times the intercept
and they get very complicated they have
the inverse tangent function for
activation as opposed to just a linear
euclidean model and you can think about
this as you have your data coming in and
you have to alter it somehow well you
alter it going down to get an answer you
end up with an error and that error goes
back up and you have to have that back
propagation with the derivative you want
to know how it changed so that you can
figure out how to adjust it for the
error
a lot of that's hidden so you don't even
have to worry about it with cross and in
today's cross you'll even if you create
your own
formula for computing an answer it will
automatically compute the back prop the
the derivative for you in a lot of cases
it's easier to implement distributed
computation
so cross is really nice way to package
it and get it off on different computers
and share it and it allows parallelism
which means that two operations can run
simultaneously
so as we start developing these back
ends it can do all kinds of cool things
and utilize multiple cores gpus on a
computer
to get that parallel processing up
what are neural networks
well like i said there are already we've
talked about in computational edges you
have a node and you have a connection or
your edge so neural networks are
algorithms fashioned after the human
brain which contain multiple layers each
layer contains a node called a neuron
which performs a mathematical operation
they break down complex problems into
simple operations
so one an input layer takes in our data
and pre-processes it
when we talk about pre-processing when
you're dealing with neural networks you
usually have to pre-process your data so
that it's between
-1 and 1 or 0-1
into some kind of value that's usable
that occurs before it gets to the neural
network
in fact 80 percent of data science is
usually in prepping that data and
getting it ready for your different
models
two you have hidden layer performs a
non-linear transformation of input
now it can do a hidden a linear
transformation it can use just a basic
euclidean geometry and you could think
of a node adding all the different
connections coming in
so each connection would have a weight
and then it would add to that weight
plus an intercept in the note itself so
you can actually use euclidean geometry
but a lot of these get really
complicated they have all these
different formulas and they're really
cool to look at but when you start
looking at them look at how they work uh
you really don't need to know the high
math behind it
um to figure them out and figure out
what they're doing
which is really cool that means a lot of
people can use this without having to go
get a phd in mathematics
number three the output layer takes the
results from hidden layer transform them
and gives a final output
so sequential models
so what makes this a sequential model
sequential models are linear stacks of
layers where one layer leads to the next
it is simple and easy to implement and
you just have to make sure that the
previous layer is the input to the next
layer
so you have used for plain stack of
layers where each layer has one input
and one output tensor and this is what
tensorflow is named after is each one of
these layers is like a tensor each each
node is a tensor and the layer is also
considered a tensor of values
and it's used for simple classifier
declassifier models you can it's also
used for regression models too so it's
not just about
this is something this is a teapot this
is a cat this is a dog
it's also used for generating um uh
regret the actual values you know this
is worth ten dollars that's worth thirty
dollars uh the weather is going to be 90
degrees out or whatever it is so you can
use it for both classifier and
declassifier models
and one more note when we talk about
sequential models the term sequential is
used a lot and it's used in different
areas and different notations when
you're in data science so when we talk
about time series we'll talk about
sequential that is something very
different uh sequential in this case
means it goes from the input to layer
one to layer two to the output so it's
very directional
it's important to note this because if
you have a sequential model can you have
a non-sequential model and the answer is
yes
if you master the basics of a sequential
model you can just as easily have
another model that shares layers
you can have another model where you
have an input coming in and it splits
and then you have one set that's doing
one set of nodes maybe they're doing a
yes no kind of node where it's either
putting out a zero or a one a classifier
and the other one might be regression
it's just processing numbers and then
you recombine them for the output
that's what they call across the cross
api
so there's a lot of different
availabilities in here and all kinds of
cool things you can do as far as
encoding and decoding and all kinds of
things and you can share layers and
things like that
we're just focusing on the basic cross
model with the sequential model
so let's dive into the meat of the
matter let's do and do a demo on here
today's demo in this demo we'll be
performing flower classification using
sequential model and cross and we'll use
our model to classify between five
different types of flowers
now for this demo and you can do this
demo on whatever platform you want or
whatever um
user interface for developing python
i'm actually using anaconda and then i'm
using jupiter notebooks to develop in
and if you're not familiar with this you
can go under environment once you've
created environment you can come in here
to open a terminal window
and if you don't have the different
modules in here you can do your conda
install whatever module it is
just happened that this particular setup
didn't have a seaborn in it which i
already installed
so here's our anaconda and then i'm
going to go back
and start up my jupiter notebook
where i already created a new
python project python 3. i'm in python
3.8 on this particular one
sequential model for flowers
so lots of fun there
so we're going to jump right into this
the first thing is to make sure you have
all your modules installed
so if you don't have a numpy pandas
matplot library and seaborn in the cross
an sklearn or sitekit it's not actually
sklearn you'll need to go ahead and
install all of those
now having done this for years and
having switched environments and doing
different things
i get all my imports done and then we
just run it and if we get an error we
know we have to go back and install
something
right off the bat though we have numpy
pandas matplot library seaborn these are
built on top of each other append is a
data frame and built on top of numpy the
data array
and then we bring in our sklearn or
scikit this is the scikit setup
sci kit
even though you use sk learn to bring it
in it's the site kit and then our cross
we have our pre-processing the images
image data generator
our model this is our basic model our
sequential model
and then we bring in from cross layers
import dents
optimizers
these optimizers a lot of them already
come in these are your different
optimizers and it's almost a lot of this
is so automatic now
atom
is the a lot of times the default
because you're dealing with a large data
and then we get our sgd which is smaller
data does better on smaller pieces of
data
and i'm not going to go into all of
these uh different optimizers we didn't
even use these in the actual demo you
just have to be aware that they are
different optimizers and the bigger the
more you dig into these models
you'll hit a point where you do need to
play with these a little bit but for the
most part leave it at the default when
you're first starting out
and we're doing just the sequential
you'll see here layers dense
and then if we come down a little bit
more when they put this together and
they're running the dense layers you'll
also see they have dropout they have
flattened they have activation
they have the convolutional
layer 2d max pooling 2d
batch normalization
what are all these layers uh and when we
get to the model we're gonna talk about
them uh a lot of times when you're just
starting you can just
import cross dot layers and then you
have your drop out your flat and
your convolutional
neural network 2d
and we'll we'll cover what these do
in the actual example when we get down
there
what i want you to take from here though
is you need to run your imports
and load your different aspects of this
and of course your tensorflow tf because
this is all built on tensorflow
and then finally uh import random is rn
just for random generation
and then we get down here we have our
cv2
that is your
open image or your opencv they call it
for processing images that's what the
cvd2 is
we have our tqdm
the
tqdm is for um it's a progress bar just
a fancy way
of adding when you're running a process
you can view the bar going across in the
jupiter
setup not really necessary but it's kind
of fun to have
we want to be able to shuffle some files
again these are all different things
pill is another
image processor it goes with the cv2 a
lot of times you'll see both of those
and so we run those we've got to bring
them all in
and the next thing is to set up our
directories
and so we come into the directories
there's an important thing to note on
here other than we're looking at a lot
of flowers which is fun
uh
as we get down here we have our
directory archive flowers that just
happens to be where the different
files for different flowers are put in
we're denoting an x and a z
and the x is the date of the image and
the z is the tag for it what kind of
flower is this
and the image size is really important
because we have to resize everything if
you have a neural network and if you
remember from our neural networks let me
flip back to that slide
we look at this light we have two input
nodes here with an image you have an
input node
depending on how you set it up for each
pixel and that pixel has three different
color schemes usually in it sometimes
four so if you have a picture that's 150
by 150
uh you multiply 150 times 150 times
three
that's how many nodes input layer is
coming in i mean so this is a massive
input a lot of times you think oh yeah
it's just a small amount of data or
something like that
no it's a full image coming in
and then you have your hidden layers a
lot of times they match what the image
size is coming in so each one of those
is also just as big and then we get down
to just a single output
so that's kind of a thing to note in
here what's going on behind the scenes
and of course each one of these layers
has a lot of processes and stuff going
on
and then we have our different uh
directories on here let me go and run
that so i'm just setting the directories
that's all this is
archive flowers daisy sunflower tulip
dandelion rose
just our different directories that
we're going to be looking at
and then we want to go ahead and we need
to assign labels remember we defined x
in z
so we're just going to create a uh
definition here
um
and the first thing is a return flower
type okay
just returns it what kind of flower it
is i guess a sign label to it uh but
we're going to go ahead and make our
train data
and when you look at this there's a
couple things to take away from here uh
the first one
is we're just appending right onto our
numpy array the image we're going to let
numpy handle all that different
aspects as far as 150 by 150 by three
we just dump it right into the numpy
which makes it really easy we don't have
to do anything funky on the processing
and we want to leave it like that and
i'm going to talk about that in a minute
and then of course we have to have the
string append the label on there and i
want you to notice right here
we're going to read the image in
and then we're going to size it and this
is important because we're just changing
this to 150 by 150 we're resizing the
image so it's uniform every image comes
in identical to the other ones uh this
is something that's so important is
when you're resizing or reformatting
your data you really have to be aware of
what's going on
with
images it's not a big deal because with
an image you just resize it so it looks
squishy or spread out or stretched
the neural network picks up on that and
it doesn't really change how it
processes it
so let's go ahead and run that
and now we've got our definition set up
on there
and then we want to go ahead and make
our
training data
so make the train data
daisy flower daisy directory
print length of x so here we go let's go
and run that
and we're just loading up the flower
daisy so this is going all in there and
it's setting
it's adding it in to the our setup on
there
to our x and z setup
and we see we have 769
and then of course you can see this nice
bar here this is the bar going across is
that little added
code in there that just makes it really
cool for doing demos
not necessarily when you're building
your own model or something like that
but if you're going to display this to
other people
adding that little what was it called
tqdm i can never remember that but the
tqdm module in there is really nice and
we'll go ahead and do sunflowers and of
course you could have just
created an array of these
but this has an interesting problem
that's going to come up and i want to
show you something
it doesn't matter how good the people in
the back are or how good you are
programming
errors are going to come up and you got
to figure out how to handle them and so
when we get all the way down to
the
[Music]
where is it dandelion here's our
dandelion directory we're going to build
jupiter has some cool things it does
which makes this really easy to deal
with
but at the same time you want to go back
in there depending on how many times you
rerun this how many times you pull this
so when you're finding errors
going in here there's a couple things
you can do and we're just going to hope
it wasn't there it is there's our error
i knew there was an error
this processed
1062 out of 1065.
now i can do a couple things one i could
go back into our definition
and i can just put in here try and so if
it has a bad conversion this is where
the error is coming from
uh just skip it that's one way to do it
when you're doing a lot of work in data
science and you look at something like
this where you're losing three points of
data at the end you just say okay i lost
three points who cares
or you can go in there and try to delete
it
it really doesn't matter for this
particular demo
and so we're just going to leave that
error right alone and skip over because
it's already added all the other files
in there and this is a wonderful thing
about jupiter notebook
is that i can just continue on there and
the x and z which we're creating
is still
running and we'll just go right into the
next flower rose so all these flowers
are in there
that's just a cool thing about jupiter
notebook
and then we can go ahead and just take a
quick look
and see
what we're dealing with and this is of
course really when you're dealing with
the other people and showing them stuff
this is just kind of fun where we can
display it on the plot library here
and we're just going to go through and
let's see what we got here
looks like
we're going to do like five of each of
them i think
is that how they set this up
plot library five by two okay oh i see
how they did it okay so two each so we
have five by two set up on our axes and
we're just going to go in and look at a
couple of these flowers
it's always a good thing to look at some
of your data
no matter what you're doing
we've reformatted this to 150 by 150
you can see how it really blurs this one
up here on the tulip
that is that resize to 150 by 150.
and these are what's actually going in
these are all 150 by 150 images you can
check the dimensions on the side
and you can see just a quick sampling of
the flowers we're actually going to
process on here
and again like i said at the beginning
most of your work in data science is
reprocessing
this different information so we need to
go ahead and take our labels
and run a label encoder on there and
then we're just going to le is a label
encoder one of the things we imported
and then we always use the fit
to categorical y comma five x here's our
array
x so if you look at this here's our fit
we're gonna transform z that's our z
array we created
and then we have y which equals that and
then we go ahead and do to categorical
we want five different categories
and then we create our x
in p array of x x equals x over 255.
so what's going on here there's two
different transformations one we've
turned our categories into
zero one two three four five as the
output
and we have taken our x array
and remember the x array is three values
of your different colors
this is so important to understand when
we do this across a numpy array this
takes every one of those three colors so
we have 150 by 150 pixels
out of those 150 by 150 pixels they each
have three
um color arrays and those clear arrays
range from zero to 250. so when we take
the x equals x over 255
i'm sorry range from zero to 255.
this converts all those pixels to a
number between zero and one
and you really want to do that when
you're working with neural networks
now if you do a linear regression model
it doesn't affect it as much and so you
don't have to do that conversion if
you're doing straight numbers but when
you're running neural networks if you
don't do this you're going to create a
huge bias
and that means it'll do really good on
predicting one or two things and they'll
just totally die on a lot of other
predictions
so now we have our
x and y values
x being the data in y being our known
output
and with any good setup we want to
divide this data into our training
so we have x train
we have our x test this is the data
we're not going to program the model
with
and of course your y train corresponds
to your x train and your y test
corresponds to your x test the outputs
and this is uh when we do the train test
split this was from the scikit sklearn
we imported train test split and we're
just going to go ahead and do the test
size at about a quarter of the data 0.25
and of course random is always good
this is such a good tool i mean
certainly you can do your own division
um
you know you could just take the first
you know 0.25 of the data or whatever do
the length of the data not real hard to
do
but this is randomized so if you're
running this test a few times you can
kind of get an idea whether it's going
to work or not
sometimes what i will do
is i'll just split the data into three
parts
and then i'll test it on two with one
being the uh or i train it on two of
those parts with one being the test and
i rotate it so i come up with three
different answers which is a good way of
finding out just how good your model is
but for setting up let's stick with the
xtranex test and the sk learn package
and then we're going to go ahead and do
a random seed
now a lot of times the cross actually
does this automatically but we're going
to go ahead and set it up on here
you can see we did an np random seed
from 42 and we get a nice rn number
and then we do tf random we set the seed
so you can set your randomness at the
beginning of your tensorflow and that's
what the
tf.random.set is
so that's a lot of prep um all this prep
and then we finally get to the exciting
part
this is where you probably spend once
you have the data prepped and you have
your pipeline going
and you have everything set up on there
this is the part that's exciting is
building these models
and so we look at this model one we're
going to designate a sequential
they have the api which is across the
cross tensorflow api versus sequential
sequential means we're going one layer
to the next so we're not going to split
the layer and bring it back together
it looks almost the same with the
exception of
bringing it back together so it's not a
huge step to go from this to an api
and the first thing we're going to look
at is
our convolutional neural network in 2d
so what's going on here there's a lot of
stuff that's going on here
the default for well let's start with
the beginning what is a convolutional 2d
network
well convolutional 2d network creates a
number of small windows and those small
windows float over the picture
and each one of them is their own neural
network and this basically
becomes like a
a categorization and then it looks at
that and it says oh if we add these
numbers up a certain way
we can find out whether this is the
right flower based on this this little
window floating around which looks at
different things
and we have filters 32 so this is
actually creating 32 windows is what
that's doing
and the kernel size is five by five so
we're looking at a five by five square
remember it's 150 by 150 so this narrows
it down to a five by five it's a two d
so it has your x y coordinates
and we look at this five by five
remember each one of these is is
actually looking at five by five by
three
so we're actually looking at 15 by 15
different
pixels
and padding is just
usually just ignore that
activation by default is relu we went
ahead and put the relu in there
there's a lot of different activations
relu is for your smaller
when you remember i mentioned atom when
you have a lot of datum data use an atom
kind of activation or using atom
processing
we're using the relu here
it kind of gives you a yes or no but it
doesn't give you a full yes or no it has
a
zero and then it kind of shoots off at
an angle
very common it's the most common one and
then of course here's our input shape
150 by 150 by 3 pixels
and then we have to pull it so whenever
you have a two convolutional 2d
layer we have to bring this back
together and pull this into a neural
network and then we're going to go ahead
and repeat this
so we're going to add another network
here
one of the cool things if you look at
this is that it as it comes in it just
kind of automatically assumes you're
going down to the next layer
and so we have another convolutional
null network 2d
here's our max pooling again we're going
to do that again max pooling
and we're just going to filter on down
now one of the things they did on this
one is they change the kernel size they
change the number of filters and so each
one of these steps
kind of looks at the data a little bit
differently
and that's kind of cool because then you
get a little added filtering on there
this is where you start playing with the
model you might be looking at a
convolutional neural network which is
great for image classifications
we get down to here one of the things we
see is flattened so we added we just
flatten it remember this is 150 by 150
by three
well and actually
the pool size changes so it's actually
smaller than that flattened just puts
that into a 1d array
so instead of being
you know a tensor of this really
complexity with the the pixels and
everything it's just flat
and then the dense
is just another activation on there
by default it is probably relu
as far as its activation
and then oh yeah here we go in
sequential they actually added the
activation as relu so this just because
this is sequential this activation is
attached to the dents
and there's a lot of different
activations but relu is the most common
one and then we also see a soft max
softmax
is similar
but it has its own kind of variation
and one of the cool things you know what
let me bring this up because if we if
you don't know about these activations
this doesn't make sense
and i just did a quick google search on
images of tensorflow activations
i should probably look at which set
website this is
but this is the output of the values
so as your x as it adds in all those
weighted x values going into the node
it's going to activate it a certain way
that's a sigmoid activation and you can
see it goes between zero and one and has
a nice curve there this also shows the
derivatives
and if we come down the seven popular
activation functions nonlinear
activations there's a lot of different
options on this let me see if i can find
the
[Music]
let's make sure we can find the specific
to relu
so this is a leaky rayloo
and you can see instead of it just being
zero and then a value between uh going
up it has a little leaky there otherwise
your railu loses some nodes they just
become inactive um but you can see
there's a lot of different options here
here's a good one right here with the
relu you can see the rayleigh function
on the upper on the upper left here and
then the leaky railway over here on the
right which is very commonly used also
one of the things i use with processing
language is the sig is the exponential
one
or the tangent h the hyperbolic tangent
because they have that nice uh funky
curve that comes in that has a whole
different meaning and captures word use
better again these are very specific to
domain and you can spend a lot of time
playing with different models
for our basic model we'll stick to the
relu and the softmax on here and we'll
go ahead and run and build this model
so now that we've had fun playing with
all these different models that we can
add in there uh we need to go ahead and
have a batch size on here uh 128
epix 10
this means that we're going to send 128
rows of data or flowers at a time to be
processed
and the epics 10 that's how many times
we're going to loop through all the data
and then there's all kinds of stuff you
can do again this is now built into a
lot of cross models already by default
so there's different ways to reduce
the values and
verbose verbose equals one means that
we're going to show what's going on
um
value the monitor what we're monitoring
we'll see that as we actually train the
model this is what's what's going to
come out of there if you set the verbose
equal to 0
you don't have to watch it train the
model
although
it is kind of nice to actually know
what's going on sometimes
and since we're still working on
bringing the data in here's our batch
side here's our epics we need to go
ahead and create a data generator this
is our image data generator
and it has all the different settings in
here almost all of these are defaults so
if you're looking at this going oh my
gosh this is confusing
most the time you can actually just
ignore most of this
vertical flip so you can randomly flip
pictures you can randomly horizontally
flick them
you can shift the picture around this
kind of helps gives you multiple data
off of them
zooming rotation there's all kinds of
different things you can do with images
most of these we're just going to leave
as false we don't really need to do all
that
setup because we already have a huge
amount of data
if you're short data you can start
flipping like a horizontal picture and
it will generate it's like doubling your
data almost
so the upside is you double your data
the downside is that if you already have
a bias in your data you already have
[Music]
5 000 sunflowers and only two roses
that's a huge bias it's also going to
double that bias
that is the downside of that
and so we have our model compile and
this you're going to see in all the
cross we're going to take this model
here
we're going to take all this information
as far as how we want it to go and we're
going to compile it
this actually builds the model and so
we're going to run that and i want you
to notice a
learning rate very important this is the
default zero zero one
there's there you really don't this is
how
slowly it adjusts to find the right
answer
and the more data you have you might
actually make this a smaller number
with larger with you have a very small
sample of data you might go even larger
than that
and then we're going to look at the loss
categorically categorical cross entropy
most commonly used
and this is how how much it improves the
model is improving is what this number
means or yeah that's that's important on
there and then the accuracy we want to
know just how good our model is on the
accuracy
and then
one of the cool things to do is if
you're in a group of people who are
studying the model if you're in
shareholders you don't want to do this
is you can run the model summary
i do this by default and you can see the
different layers that you built into
this model just a quick summary on there
so we went ahead and we're going to go
ahead and create a
we'll call it history but we want to do
a model fit generator
and so what this history is doing is
this is tracking what's going on as
while it fits
the model
now there's a lot of new setups in here
where they just use fit and then you put
the generator in here
um
we're going to leave it like this even
though the new default
is a little different on that it doesn't
really matter it does the same thing and
we'll go ahead and just run that
and you can see while it's running right
here we're going through the epics we
have one of 10 now we're going through 6
to 25
here's our loss we're printing that out
so you can see how it's improving and
our accuracy the accuracy gets better
and better and this is 6 out of 25 this
is going to take a couple minutes to
process
because we are training 150 by 150 by 3
pixels across
six layers or eight layers whatever it
was
that is a huge amount of processing so
this will take a few minutes to process
this is when we talk about the hardware
and the problems that come up in data
science and why it's only now just
exploding being able to do neural
networks this is why this process takes
a long time
now you should have seen a jump on the
screen here because i did
pause the recorder to let this go ahead
and run all the way through its epics
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what these epics are
and if you set the verbose to
zero instead of one it won't show what's
going on in the behind the scenes as
it's training it
so we look at this epic tin epic so we
went through all the data ten times uh
if i remember correctly there's roughly
a gig of data there so that's a lot of
data
the first thing you're going to notice
is the
270 seconds
that's how much each of those epics took
to run
and so if you divide 60 in there you
roughly get about five minutes worth of
each epic so if i have 10 epics that's
50 minutes almost an hour of run time
that's a big deal we talk about
processing uh in on this particular
computer
i actually have what is it
eight cores with 16 dedicated threads so
it runs like a 16 core computer it
alternates the threads going in
and it still takes it five minutes for
each one of these epics so you start to
see that if you have a lot of data this
is going to be a problem if you have a
number of models you want to find out
how good the models are doing what model
to use
and so each of those models could take
all night to run in fact i have a model
i'm running now that takes over
takes about a day and a half to test
each model
it takes four days to do the whole data
so what i do is i actually take a small
piece of the data
test it out to find out
get an idea of how the different setups
are going to do
and then i increase that size of the
data and then increase it again and i
can just take that that curve and kind
of say okay if the data is doing this
then i need to add in more dense layers
or whatever
so you can do a small chunks of data and
figure out what it costs to do a large
set of data and what kind of model you
want
the loss as we see here continues to go
down
this is the error this is how much error
is in there it really isn't a
user-friendly number other than
the more it trends down the better and
so if you continue to see the loss going
down eventually get to the point where
it stops going down and it goes up and
down and kind of wavers a little bit at
that point you know you've run too many
epics you're starting to get a bias in
there and it's not going to give you a
good model fit
the accuracy just turns us into
something that
we can use
and so the accuracy is what percentage
of guesses in this case is categorical
so this is the percentage of guesses are
correct
um value loss is similar you know it's a
minus a value loss
and then you have the value accuracy and
you'll see the value accuracy is pretty
similar to the accuracy
just rounds it off basically and so a
lot of times you come down here and you
go okay we're doing 0.5.6
0.7 and that is 70 accuracy or in this
case 68.2
accuracy that's a very usable number and
it's very important to have
if you're identifying flowers that's
probably good enough if you can get
within a close distance in knowing what
flower you're identifying
if you're trying to figure out whether
someone's going to die from a heart
attack or not you might want to rethink
it a little bit or re-key how you're
building your model
so
if i'm working with a
a group of clients
shareholders in a company or something
like that
you don't really want to show them this
you don't want to show them hey you know
this is what's going on with the
accuracy these are just numbers and so
we want to go and put the finishing
touches just like when you are building
a house and you put in the frame and the
trim on the house it's nice to have
something a nice view of what's going on
and so we'll go ahead and do a pie plot
and we'll just plot the history of the
loss
the history of the
value loss
over here
epics train and test and so we're just
going to compute these
this is really important and what i want
you to notice right here is when we get
to about oh
five epics a little more than five six
epics you see a cross over here
and it starts crossing as far as the um
value loss and what's going on here is
you have the loss in your actual model
and your actual data and you have the
value loss where it's testing it against
the the test data the data wasn't used
to program your model wasn't used to
train your model on
and so when we see this crossing over
this is where the bias is coming in this
is becoming over fitted and so when you
put these two together uh right around
five and six you start to see how it
does this this switch over here and
that's really where you need to stop
right around five yeah six
um
it's always hard to guess because at
this point the model is kind of a black
box
see but you know that right around here
if you're saving your model after each
run you want to use the one that's right
around five epics because that's the one
that's going to have the least amount of
bias so this is really important as far
as guessing what's going on with your
model and its accuracy and when to stop
it also is you know i don't show people
this mess up here
i show somebody this kind of model i say
this is where the training and the
testing comes in on this model
it just makes it easier to see and
people can understand what's going on
so that completes our demo and you can
see we did what we were set out to do we
took our flowers and we were able to
classify them uh within about you know
68 70 accuracy whether it's going to be
a dahlia sunflower cherry blossom rose
a lot of other things you can do with
your output as far as a
different tables to see
where the errors are coming from and
what problems are coming up
and with that we come to the end of this
video on keras we really hope that you
enjoyed this video
if you did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated
also here's your reminder to subscribe
to our channel and click on the bell
icon for more on the latest technologies
and trends
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more
from simply learn
you